si vous cherchez un aspirateur robot
pour la maison pratique intelligent qui
sait tout faire il est là c'est le 10
bottes X1 omni l'aspirateur robot vient
se ranger très facilement ici sur son
stand et si vous avez plein de surprises
déjà sur le haut si vous ouvrez vous
avez deux réservoirs d'eau un réservoir
d'eau propre dans lequel vous venez
mettre trois litres d'eau propre ça
c'est vachement bien votre eau ensuite
elle va descendre elle va aller sur
l'aspirateur robot vous avez ensuite un
bac dos sale dans lequel toutes vos
trous qui a servi au nettoyage et bien
elle est là elle est stocker vous avez
plus qu'à venir la vider vous avez 3,2
litres dans un bac comme dans l'autre ce
qui vous donne jusqu'à 60 jours de
nettoyage sans venir toucher ici à vos
bagues d'eau et ce qui est cool c'est
qu'en plus ici vous avez des petits
accessoires vous le prenez vous avez une
petite brossette pour venir nettoyer
vous avez des petits patins de rechange
bref il est extrêmement pratique et en
plus de ça il y a un autre point qui est
vachement bien c'est à dire que tout ce
qui est aspiré vient remonter ici
directement dans un sac que vous n'avez
besoin de changer que de temps en temps
vous êtes peinard donc ici on a
l'aspirateur tout-en-un qui vous servira
pour la maison très facilement et son
nom c'est les covacs 10 bottes X1 omni
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec Ecovacs je
vous ai déjà présenté il y a pas
longtemps le 10 bot X1 turbo qui est son
petit frère vous avez plusieurs produits
dans la gamme il y a de plus le turbo et
la l'omnie l'omnie c'est celui qui offre
le plus façon de parler premier truc à
voir ici c'est le design c'est un design
qui était fait par Jacob Jensen design
élégant sympathique lorsque vous levez
ici et bien vous allez retrouver votre
bouton pour venir l'allumer pour
l'éteindre le reset pour le wifi un
petit bac vous allez avoir toutes les
cochonneries alors celui là on va
vraiment jamais toucher parce que
l'intérêt de cet aspirateur robot ce qui
est vraiment génial c'est que en réalité
vous ne le toucherez jamais si ce n'est
pour venir à changer le filtre que vous
avez là si ce n'est pour venir changer
les patins que vous avez en dessous si
ce n'est pour venir changer
éventuellement les brossettes mais dans
très longtemps c'est tout pas plus pas
moins parce que ce qui est cool c'est
que avant de partir il va se remplir en
eau propre lorsqu'il a fini vide son eau
sale et il vide également toutes les
cochonneries qu'il a aspiré donc vous ne
touchez pas vous n'avez pas besoin de le
toucher il fait le taf tout seul donc
vous êtes tranquille vous avez les mains
libres ce qui est génial c'est que vous
aurez besoin de changer l'eau et de
vider le sac à poussière de temps en
temps et uniquement de temps en temps
donc vous avez juste vous besoin de le
programmer je vais vous montrer dans
l'application comment faire dans
quelques instants et lui fera le boulot
tout seul et c'est transparent pour vous
et pour le peu vous le programmer
lorsque vous partez au travail vous ne
vous rendrez même pas compte le ménage a
été fait vous aurez toujours une maison
propre et ça c'est vachement bien
[Musique]
alors si vous le savez pas ecovac c'est
un des leaders du marché des aspirateurs
robots qui vient vous proposer des
solutions hyper intéressantes pour la
maison le tarif de l'omni c'est
1299 euros et s'il vous intéresse bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien juste en
bas dans la description allez dessus
cliquez comme ça vous en saurez plus la
différence que vous avez par rapport au
turbo que je vous ai présenté il y a
quelques semaines quelques bonnes
semaines maintenant c'est le vidage
automatique dans le sac c'est vachement
pratique parce qu'il y a une vraie
différence si vous avez le turbo et bien
vous devez venir vider votre sac et
mettre les cochonneries directement dans
la poubelle avec l'omnie vous ne le
faites pas il se vide directement comme
je vous le disais vous videz le sac de
temps en temps et vous êtes peinard
alors au départ c'est très simple il va
venir lui scanner votre maison qu'est-ce
qu'il fait et bien vous déclenchez le
scan rapide pour venir reconnaître votre
maison et la différence par rapport aux
anciennes générations où il devait venir
aspirer passer faire le tour complet et
après vous voyez le plan de votre maison
là il se balade et comme vous avez une
caméra d'étoffe qui est en gros un laser
il va reconnaître les il va reconnaître
les meubles et il verra les différents
espaces et l'autre truc qui est génial
c'est que vous avez jusqu'à trois étages
donc si vous avez une maison jusqu'à
trois étages il va venir mémoriser
jusqu'à trois cartes le nettoyage et ça
c'est un truc qui est vachement bien
vous avez ça là les petites brossettes
qui vont venir tourner 180 tours par
minute autant vous dire que ça il va et
ça il va franco vous avez la succion qui
se fait ici c'est à dire que en fait lui
il va avancer les petites brossettes
vont venir tomber dans ce sens pour
ramener les cochonneries ici là vous
avez jusqu'à 5000 Pascal de puissance
d'aspiration quand vous dire que ça vous
ramasse tout et ensuite on va venir
nettoyer par derrière comme ça vous en
nettoyage complet vous êtes vraiment
peinard autre truc qui est très bien
c'est comme ici voyez on est monté sur
une espèce de petit ressort et bien on
va passer les paliers de porte
extrêmement facilement donc pas de
galère pour la maison il y a un autre
truc qui est différent par rapport au
turbo c'est qui si vous avez un séchage
par air chaud ce que ça va faire une
fois qu'il est revenu à sa base et bien
il va venir sécher un petit peu on va
appeler ça des patins de nettoyage pour
éviter qu'il y a des bactéries qui
prolifèrent dessus donc ça les sèche à
l'air chaud et c'est cool la
cartographie se fait grâce aux caméras
que vous avez ici et au laser vous avez
là il va venir connaître très facilement
votre maison c'est-à-dire identifier des
objets identifier des personnes il va
même vous faire des petites photos vous
pouvez venir dire tiens c'est quoi cet
objet tiens il y a quoi il y a si et ça
donc si vous avez par exemple un animal
à la maison que ce soit un chien ou un
chat ou un hamster peut-être aller
savoir lui il va venir le reconnaître
très facilement et éviter de foncer
dessus pareil vous vous êtes assis par
terre en train de j'en sais rien vous y
mettre assis par terre et bien il va
venir vous contourner il va pas vous
foncer dessus autre truc qui est
vachement bien vous avez un assistant
vocal il faut lui dire ok
ICO Gap pour que il se lance pas
directement vous donner la petite phrase
magique et vous allez lui donner plein
d'ordre va nettoyer cette zone va
nettoyer si il fait ça retourne bref
vous lui dites ce que vous voulez et une
fois de plus c'est l'idée de ne pas
venir le toucher tout se fait ici par la
voix ou alors via l'application je vous
montre ça dans quelques instants tout en
sachant quand même qu'ici il est
compatible Google assistant et Amazon
Alexa niveau de l'autonomie aussi on est
très très bon on a une batterie de 5200
milliampères heure et si toutefois vous
avez une maison extrêmement grande et
qu'il devait retourner se charger il
retournerait chargé et il continuerait
son ménage donc une fois de plus pour
vous c'est totalement transparent et
alors vous me direz ok ça c'est bien
sympa mon bon mot monsieur gros je vais
avoir mes petites brossettes qui vont
tourner pour venir faire le nettoyage
mais si j'ai un tapis qu'est-ce qui va
se passer et bien en fait c'est
extrêmement malin déjà il va venir faire
un truc c'est que lui grâce à ses
capteurs il va reconnaître s'il est sur
un tapis ou pas s'il est sur un tapis il
fait quoi il va mettre la scission max
il va spirer au maximum ici pour venir
ramasser toutes les cochonneries sur
votre tapis et là il va venir relever
ses brosses pour ne pas venir frotter
directement sur le tapis ça ne sert à
rien de nettoyer tapis avec ça donc bon
comme ça il va venir s'adapter il
reconnaît et une fois de plus on est
dans l'idée de l'intelligence et de
l'outil très simple à utiliser à la
maison
[Musique]
les trucs est super intéressant c'est
que vous gérez tout directement dans une
application l'application c'est Ecovacs
home regardez votre aspirateur connecté
ici vous en avez plusieurs moi j'ai le
turbo il est en ligne parce qu'il n'est
pas ici mais là j'ai l'omnie je vois mon
niveau de batterie je vois qu'il est en
ligne je peux lancer un nettoyage
automatique je peux lui dire d'aller
retourner à la base et d'aller se
charger et ensuite je peux accéder au
nettoyage intelligent accéder aux
gestionnaires vidéo ici aussi si je le
souhaite et là j'ai mon petit icône pour
mon assistant vocal intelligent
d'ailleurs j'ai un petit tuto qui
m'explique comment ça se passe donc si
vous ne savez pas vous pouvez y aller
démarrage rapide nettoyer et compagnie
donc ça c'est très très cool on vous
prend une fois plus par la main on vient
vous aider si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez accéder à l'enregistrement vidéo
c'est à dire venir enregistrer ce qui se
passe chez vous j'ai un mot de passe je
tape mon mot de passe donc là je peux
venir enregistrer très facilement je
peux venir inspecter le logement faire
un appel vocal il y a un côté un peu de
sécurité pour la maison si vous le
souhaitez et vérifiez que tout se passe
bien si vous êtes en vacances il peut y
avoir un côté un peu pratique là-dessus
vraiment mais ce qui nous intéresse
surtout nous c'est la question du
nettoyage donc accéder au nettoyage
intelligent là je veux retrouver ma
maison alors ici c'est une seule et même
grande pièce donc je suis venu faire des
zones mettre des zones pour vraiment
différencier ce qui se passe le côté
bureau là tout de suite voyez c'est là
où on est en train de tourner vous avez
le petit salon derrière vous voyez ici
on va voir la salle à manger le petit
bout de cuisine qui se situe juste là là
je vois que j'ai ma zone de recherche
qui est là tout de suite et après je
peux venir gérer ce qui va s'afficher
directement l'agencement les étiquettes
la couleur des hommes préférence de
nettoyage séquence de nettoyage et je
retrouve une fois de plus mon assistant
vocal qui est juste là je peux venir
l'activer désactiver je vais retrouver
les commandes très facilement pour venir
m'aider une fois de plus et savoir
comment communiquer avec lui là j'ai la
durée du dernier nettoyage la zone
nettoyée pas extrêmement grand ici non
plus donc là je peux venir éditer mes
zones je peux gérer ma carte donc là je
vois que c'est ma carte je peux venir la
renommer je peux avoir différentes
cartes en fonction de mes différents
étages bien sûr donc là en cliquant sur
zone je vais l'envoyer nettoyer une zone
en particulier si je clique sur
Automatique il va aller tout nettoyer de
façon automatique de façon intelligente
tu vas venir personnaliser également je
peux lui dire ben tiens tu vas venir
nettoyer par ici là j'ai fait tomber
quelque chose c'est vraiment le bazar ok
je clique et il partira nettoyer ici je
peux le supprimer si je souhaite
également et ensuite je vais avoir plein
d'options vachement pratique en dessous
préférence de nettoyage standard ou
personnalisé première personnaliser très
facilement préférence de zone je peux
lui dire dans telle zone par exemple tu
vas me faire ça dans cette zone là par
exemple le salon je veux que tu viennes
nettoyer une fois ou deux fois si
j'estime que c'est vraiment très très
sale comme endroit je peux régler le
niveau d'aspiration une aspiration très
silencieuse standard maximum et la
carrément max plus ça envoie du bois bon
ok standard Samira le débit d'eau faible
moyen ou élevé et ça je le fais pour
toutes les zones que ce soit le bureau
la salle à manger ou la cuisine je peux
estimer que dans la cuisine par exemple
je vais en mettre plus faire tomber des
choses on nettoie plus fort la salle à
manger également ça dépendra de vous et
comment vous vivez chez vous et ça je
peux le faire pour différentes cartes
ensuite je donne des règles standard tu
nettoies une fois deux fois la puissance
d'aspiration ça on l'a vu et le débit
d'eau également le mode serpillière
standard ou alors un mode serpillière en
profondeur ou alors mode serpillière
uniquement uniquement disponible en mode
d'aspiration et de serpillière dans ce
mode 10 bottes ne passe pas l'aspirateur
il est recommandé de nettoyer le sol
avant l'activation comme ça lui passe il
fait de nettoyer le sol et après j'ai
des séquences de nettoyage si je le
souhaite tu vas par exemple commencer
par le salon tu fais la salle à manger
tu fais le bureau tu fais la cuisine
avoir à bien évidemment en fonction de
la configuration de votre maison ensuite
le nettoyage intelligent c'est à dire
quotidien environ 15 minutes efficace 25
minutes en profondeur 10 minutes pour
les intervalles de nettoyage le temps de
séchage à l'air chaud deux heures trois
heures quatre heures le vidage
automatique fréquence de village et bien
automatique ou intelligent à vous de
voir la reprise du nettoyage parce que
cette fonction est activée 10 bottes
poursuit les tâches inachevés dès
qu'elle est complètement chargée on va
faire ça on va l'activer c'est très bien
aspiration puissante automatique oui la
carte en 3D bien évidemment et l'unité
ici on est en mètre carré le programme
de nettoyage qui est extrêmement
important donc là on va venir créer un
planning définir la durée là par exemple
je vois qu'il est 11h54 je peux choisir
ma durée je peux dire de le répéter oui
ou non quel jour par exemple lundi mardi
mercredi jeudi vendredi il y a personne
à la maison entre par exemple j'en sais
rien moi entre 9h du matin et 17h donc
je vais lui dire tu vas passer le matin
et tu me nettoie tout de fond ton comble
par contre le week-end on est là tu vas
passer peut-être l'après-midi à 16h de
16h à 17h quand on est sorti se balader
et on peut mettre des préférences
automatiques ou alors une fois de plus
le faire par zone et par carte la langue
ici j'ai choisi français vous choisissez
le volume et vous avez plein d'autres
réglages pour votre assistant vocal je
vous l'ai montré c'est une autre façon
d'y arriver ici votre journal de
nettoyage vous voyez exactement là où il
est passé et ce qui s'est passé la durée
du nettoyage les accessoires et les
pièces vous voyez les États en fait
brosse latérale tout va bien brosse
principale tout va bien le filtre on est
ok tout est ok tout va bien la lingette
va bien le sac à poussière il vous
explique comment venir le changer et les
solutions de nettoyage ecovax vous allez
pouvoir mettre ici dans votre bac d'eau
propre le nettoyage intelligent qu'on a
également vu tout à l'heure gestionnaire
vidéo avec un mot de passe pour la vidéo
c'est quand même mieux de venir
sécuriser une fonction ne pas déranger
tu ne passeras pas à telle heure et à
telle heure et vous avez des
fonctionnalités de laboratoire
élimination stratégique des particules
enfin cette fonction est activée 10
bottes nettoies stratégiquement les
grosses particules de saleté pour
qu'elle ne soit pas projetée par la
brosse latérale tournante voilà on peut
venir activer ça si on le souhaite à
propos de la station voilà vous pouvez
bien le trouver si vous l'avez perdu et
un autre que je vous ai pas montré ici
dans votre carte venir la modifier très
facilement c'est à dire ajouter des
limites virtuelles activer en mode
lavage aspiration qui va en mode lavage
allez on va dire ça comme ça aspiration
et lavage tu peux me donner une zone où
je ne veux pas qu'il aille par exemple
ne va pas autour de mon canapé ici je
trouve c'est pas la bonne idée tu n'y
vas pas ou alors mettre juste un mur ici
un mur virtuel je dis ok tu ne vas pas
ici s'est passé tu ne vas pas aller dans
tout ce coin tu n'y vas pas bon une fois
de plus c'est vraiment avoir en fonction
de votre configuration et de votre
intérieur vous pouvez venir étiqueter
les zones également alors moi je l'ai
mis vous voyez j'ai mis le salon j'ai
mis le bureau la salle à manger et la
cuisine vous avez plein de possibilités
à vous de voir en fonction de votre plus
de votre intérieur vous pouvez diviser
des zones vous dire ben tiens par
exemple le salon je vais le diviser en
deux c'est pas le salon ici et ça ou
alors les fusionner je vais dire qu'en
fait le bureau et le salon c'est la
seule et même pièce voilà moi j'ai
plutôt venu diviser parce que je sais
par exemple que je vais pas vivre de la
même manière dans la partie salle à
manger dans le parti salon et les
déchets ne seront globalement
potentiellement pas les mêmes et lorsque
j'ai un autre étage chez moi que j'en ai
déjà cartographier je n'ai qu'à cliquer
ICI sur cartographier rapide et il va
venir scanner très facilement mon
intérieur
voilà vous savez tout sur cette
aspirateur robot ça le 10 bottes X1 omni
le plus complet le plus compétent le
meilleur aspirateur robot à ce jour chez
Ecovacs il vous intéresse une fois de
plus je vous mets le lien juste en bas
dans la description personnellement je
trouve extrêmement intéressant parce
qu'il fait tout ici et je ne m'embête
pas je le laisse bosser très facilement
merci à ikoax d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo puis si vous avez des questions
interrogations suggestion vous pouvez y
aller en bas dans les commentaires et
s'il vous intéresse une fois de plus je
vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]